the loss of Henry cavill's Superman is a
sad twist and a tale of a struggling
franchise and now DC's latest move has
got fans scratching their heads Warner
Brothers has thrown DC fans another
curveball with the Studio's latest
decision regarding the DC Universe the
media giant first sends shockwaves to
the industry when it decided to scrap
the nearly finished Batgirl movie in the
summer of 2022 anxieties began to quell
however when Guardians of the Galaxy and
The Suicide Squad director James Gunn
took charge at DC Studios alongside
co-ceo Peter Safran effectively becoming
DC's equivalent of Marvel Studios
president Kevin feige some fans however
quickly took issue with gun and
saffron's Swift creative choices the new
DC regime kicked off with an
announcement in December that actor
Henry Cavill would not be returning a
Superman having played the character in
a number of DC EU projects He most
recently made a cameo appearance in a
post-credits scene in 2022's Black Adam
Black Adam
we should talk
the decision shocked fans especially
after Dwayne Johnson and Cavill had made
such a public hoopla about the Return of
Superman beyond that Cavalry turning had
implied that audiences would finally see
Johnson's Black Adam and the son of
Krypton square off in a long-awaited
sequel to Man of Steel following this
news Johnson revealed that teth Adam
would not be involved in gun and
saffron's first chapter of Storytelling
effectively moving on from as much hyped
DC role with both gavel and Johnson
calling it curtains and their heroic
characters Warner Brothers latest
decision regarding Man of Steel and
Black Adam is pretty bewildering despite
the shelving of these iterations of the
characters Warner Brothers has released
a new two film collection of Man of
Steel and Black Adam on the Microsoft
store as well as various other digital
storefronts the bundle was released
shortly after Black Adam hit video on
demand both films can be purchased
together for 29.99 the two film
collection seems to be another mixed
message for DC fans however some of whom
had previously tempted to get James Gunn
fired after the director promised a new
younger man of steel for his upcoming
self-penned Superman film unsurprisingly
fan reception towards the Black Adam and
Man of Steel bundle has been mixed one
where this user wrote this is just
disrespectful others found the
collection's existence funny with one
user saying this is as close to the real
thing that Dwayne Johnson's ever gonna
get while The Logical option would have
been bundling Black Adam in 2019 Shazam
instead it's easy to see why Warner
Brothers released this collection the
marketing for Black Adam largely rested
on the return of Cavill so it makes
sense that DC wanted to celebrate the
digital release of Johnson's flick by
bundling it with Superman's ultimately
the bundle is simply a matter of poor
timing meanwhile James Gunn and Peter
saffron have largely remained
tight-lived regarding their plans for DC
what DC fans do know is that the
upcoming Superman Project won't be an
origin story with gun confirming the
news on Twitter the new DC boss also
made it clear that Warner Brothers will
be moved moving forward with the release
of movies currently in production such
as Blue Beetle and Aquaman the lost
kingdom reports have also emerged that
the flash will kickstarter's marketing
campaign with a TV spot during the 2023
Super Bowl the status of other
steiniverse characters is currently
unknown however which only makes Warner
Brothers new home release bundle or the
more puzzling still maybe the two film
collection could be seen as a respectful
farewell to two Titans of a franchise
neither of whom is expected to return at
least not anytime soon
foreign